the demon
okay d4 knight f6
c4 e6
e3 logical logical d5
knight f3 bishop d6 usually people don't
play e3 this early in the game but it's
all right
a3 interesting then this down
before maybe i'll take
not sure about e5 it's a sensible break
in most cases
[Music]
hmm
take your time find it yourself first
okay let's go for the closed position
yeah it was intending something
but just click when it's on
i'll take movie with the pawn
not good what i've done but it's all
right
could be worse could certainly be better
knight f6
three also there sometimes in the mix h4
not sure helps him
suffer weakens a little bit the king
side
but he has inhaled the alpha zero spirit
don't really know what i'm gonna do
about the
um well i can go nade this
x-men hope he doesn't
find the bravery for d5 d5 is very good
at least practically speaking
yeah this i'm fine with he's played
bishop
right yeah he did yeah it's just i don't
really care i think
excuse me a temple
and not gonna even
i really don't know what to do about the
situation here
everything is fine i think i can take it
i cannot take it i can also
yeah i'll just make a g6 maybe i'll try
to take it to the queen
with queen f8 or just ignore it
roxy one it's fine i'll bring the knight
to e4
trade i trade
yeah he's really busted with his pieces
in the corner
51 is good just gotta try to
yeah it's actually a very good uh
praying attempt
okay i'll just between this section wait
maybe i should do something smart and
close up in the face
takes takes 21 h6 takes knight g4
at f1 okay that's fine i will take the
pawn right
g5
e1 interesting
can i get in your house
yes and now
we can only trade
queen on g5 goes to b5 or
he's got d5 there i don't think he's
gonna go d5
can you see two
95 2493
knight g4 24 not that's not good maybe i
can push d5
you know it would be nice let's add this
stick let's do that
foreign
i wish i could say the position looks
great for black
but i can't tell how it looks
wait where was the queen choose this
last move
on d2 yeah but it's made in two i think
isn't it
yeah okay okay okay okay okay